Film Courage: What are you top ten tips for
producing a movie?
John Paul Rice, Producer of A CHILD’S VOICE:
Top ten tips, wow.
Script, passion about the script,
Attack everything you do with reckless abandon
in terms of this is your passion,
Work with people that you get along with (you
have a mutual respect for) both in your profession
as well as there is a personal identification.
You don’t have to agree with everything
but a shared principle about how to work,
how you want to work (that three right?).
Don’t rush things. Don’t make artificial
deadlines that don’t mean anything other
than what you think if your head. That means
life for example don’t rush to get a film
done cutting corners whether it be in preproduction,
production or post production all to meet
whatever deadline you’ve set that you have
to hit in order…if it’s a distributor
giving you a deadline, okay. If it’s you
trying to get in this one festival, you’ve
got to really weigh whether to cut those corners.
And the reason why I say that is in that haste
to get there you’ll forget certain things
that are important. And it’s not about just
racing to the deadline, it’s about thinking
your plan through very clearly so it ties
into that fourth and fifth part which is start
from the end and work your way back. Don’t
start here and go forward without knowing
where you’re going to end up and seeing
what that place looks like at the very end
when you arrive at the finished part of your
film or the distribution of your film. It’s
like an objective (a clear objective) this
is where I need to be at this stage and it
should be a logical conclusion because everything
should flow forward as it flows backwards
as well. You won’t miss anything that way.
Review your budget, look at it daily…all
the time. Even if you’re not a guy who writes
up the budget or a woman who writes up the
budget. Whatever it is, study it, become a
student of it because here is what will happen
and I know this from my own experience, we
had a problem on the last film, a piece of
equipment got broken and would have stopped
the whole filming but knowing what I had in
the budget, knowing what we had available,
I knew we could get through it and I was able
to make a split-second decision to start calling
and getting while I was in Riverside I had
to go to LA and I knew it was5:00o’clock
and everything closed at6:00 p.m.
So I had to put game-mode on, I wasn’t gong
to get over there so I had to go “Who do
we know in LA that we can have once we purchase
it and go pick it up and I can go pick it
up later that night so I can drive it back
to set?”
But all of that I did over calm when what
had just unfolded could have been a potential
disaster but because I knew how much money
we had, I knew what we wanted to do, I knew
where to start, and within 30 minutes we had
an answer and a solution and it was done.
So study the budget, it will benefit you in
ways that you won’t even know at the time.
Film Courage: That’s six?
John: We’re at six. I’m sure there are
more.
Film Courage: Four more to go. I think the
most important thing is to have trust in the
people that you work with and that is incumbent
on you. In other words, you set the table
and everybody else that you invite to that
table is going to be participating in it.
So vet the people you’re going to work with.
For the actors (and this is just if you’re
doing the micro budget, you don’t have lawyers,
people to control the behavior of others),
don’t necessarily go for the most talented
if it’s going to cause you a headache. If
you know it’s going to cause you a headache
and it raises red flags, I meet with all the
talent one-on-one, after the audition, after
the call back, after the final callback. Some
of them don’t like that process that’s
fine. But the fourth and final is the meeting
one-on-one and I have to know where their
motivations are, what kind of person they
are, not as an actor but as the kind of person
they are going to be as a person on set
that I’m going to be in close quarters with,
I’m going to be working with four hours
long at a time. So just think and if you don’t
find who you want and it doesn’t sit…it
doesn’t agree with you in here, keep looking,
keep looking to the very end. Go to every
avenue that you can. I did this with out leads.
We had tons of talented actors and through
the process it just whittled itself down and
the opportunity presented itself because I
didn’t give up and I didn’t stop looking
and I found people that I just loved from
their profession to their person and I would
work with them again in a heartbeat. If I
have a role, I’ll do it. They are just great
human beings. And they’re wonderfully talented.
So…we’re at seven? Eight, nine and ten?
Film Courage: I think you just have two more?
John: Gosh, allow yourself to evolve with
the work that you’re doing. In other words
what you thought once when you started and
what happens there in on out, let that be
your journey that guides you, in other words
let that part of the process enrich you and
give you that valuable feedback that you want
and need as a human being in order to grow
as an artist and in order to grow as a filmmaker.
I can’t say enough about this because I
think it’s often that we ignore these things
that we’re human beings first and that we
have certain sensitives and things that bother
us and issues that come up and if our goal
and our focus is about the work and the relationship
to it in both ourselves and the people that
we’re bringing to that table, you can achieve
so much more. I personally believe this just
having the experience of doing it people will
work that little extra harder that you always
wanted them to do without asking because you’re
leading by example and you’ve brought people
into that mix that have the same, same characteristic
within themselves and it’s all the sudden
“Oh? This person is like this. This person
is like this? Oh? I’m among people like
me.” They’re all doing the same thing
where you have a sound guy who’s like taking
bags out of things that are not his. Being
there to help you. This is what makes it worthwhile.
It’s not struggle and all the hardships
and everything else that you have to deal
with. That’s fine but to override and overcome
all of that and deal with it head on, make
it come from within you and let that idea
and inspiration and that passion flow and
have other people come into it who feel that
passion in you and are inspired by it. It’s
like “This is why I got into filmmaking.
I got into it for art and I’m hoping the
art will give me the opportunity will give
me the opportunity for more art or bigger
art or whatever it is.
But that’s probably the most important thing
I can say is that allow yourself to learn
from the process and don’t be so dogged
and fixated on a specific vision that it’s
not about being contrarian or throwing out
what you believe but let that belief system
evolve. Let it grow deeper, let it get richer,
let it enrich you and the people that you’re
working from because at the end of the day,
at the end of all of this when I’m an old
man regardless of where I end up, I have all
of these beautiful memories of working with
people that and remembering those moments
on set and how I felt and that is like getting
to relive your life a second time and enjoy
it. And I know that may be nine?
Film Courage: That’s okay, it’s two-in-one
right there. That was so excellent. I think
that may be why with your last film (I know
you have two more in pre-production) A CHILD’S
VOICE, you felt like even at that premiere
and you’re basically closing down [staying
until it closes] Barney’s Beanery, you felt
that synergy that maybe the other projects
that were good times but there was something
different because you went by those [tenets]
what you’re saying right now.
John: Yes, I let the work guide me and the
material and put my belief system in what
we were doing and the good it could do first,
it wasn’t about being a filmmaker in the
sense of producing and all of the functional
stuff, everybody did there job and they came
with their tools to do a great job and so
it was more about that emotion and the feeling
of having created something that everybody
was really proud of in themselves not for
just the craft of it was this like…we did
something…we did something…Oh my gosh,
it affected people…Oh my gosh?
And grown women coming out and crying and
holding on to our actors and saying “I didn’t
know that this existed and that this happened.”
And they don’t know each other, she’s
coming up…there was such a strong reaction.
That is so valuable as a human-to-human-thing,
to connect with another human being that is
“not your own.” And it spoke to a deeper
thing about the movie which is THE CHILD’S
VOICE is the calling of the child within us.
And the answer to the child that is not you
or yours to say I will protect you, I will
help you, I will risk my life because that
in itself is our mammal part (the human part)
of us that makes us different from a reptile.